Ayy, this is the best game ever
This is the best game. This is the best game ever!
Best game, 10 out of 10
,  let's play. Best game ever
BEST GAME EVER!
Best game ever - Any game where you can drag out the ass is the best game ever
[chuckle] Best game ever
Oh best game ever here, best game ever there, Felix.
Finally
finally, finalmente
[de slutar vi] we got the beh- we have the best game ever, okay?
And I'll tell you why it's the best game ever because I helped work on it. That's right.
I'm talking of course about Animal. Super. Squad. Short for ASS
It's the best game ever. I made it together
with Armin. It's our love child. Armin is the guy who came up with goat simulator, that idea and
together, with a fantastic team of double moose who put their heart and soul into this, we have
Animal Super Squad. I am genuinely so proud of this, even though I put barely any effort in it
A lot of people have been asking what what my role in this game is, I can't make games obviously
I'm not a developer, but so I've been more of a creative outlook,
produced the game. It
started off - Let's start a game, and then I can talk over it cuz it starts off pretty simple
It start- heh heh I love this character
We made the puffer fish just cuz Martzia loves puffer fishes so much and they're so cute
I'm getting so sidetracked, God dammit. You can play the puffer fish everybody, there you go
This is-
You know we've been talking about this game for years. Literally
It was a product that went through Revelmode, which was my company together with Disney
but you know, you all know how that story went so I took over this project independently and
then it came through with doublemoose. It's a long story
I'm just amazed that it survived the whole Wall Street Journal apocalypse and all that.
I'm just so proud and excited that it's finally
Finally out. So the game starts off pretty simple
It's sort of inspired by
trials and happy wheels
we really wanted to make a game where the community has the biggest aspect of it and
A lot a lot of time and effort went into making the level editor, which I'll show you later
Where you can really make some crazy,
chaotic
shit, and personally, I can't wait for to play you guys levels and maps and whatever
It's gonna be so much fun
I can't wait to see what the community of this game
will be. I have a lot of- it's a lot of stuff for me to say and a lot of thoughts coming in at once
I don't know, should I just play the game and shut the fuck up or-
MÅL like in Sweden. Very nice by the way. Alright, I lost the vehicle, but we're gonna we're gonna continue
as per usual
Because who needs a vehicle
When you can just walk. This is realistic walking animations here
We really went all for realism in this game. As you can tell cause the apple just exploded.
so the game is in early access
so it starts up with this area
We have a ton of new other areas
coming up. Let's do- let's do something more advanced.
CELOSIA
We have Ethan, straight up plagiarized character
EEEHHHEH
O we get the new vehicle as well
this one can fly, but you can also tell we take everything very seriously in this game
This is practically
the walking simulator
of video games. We really hope this one will take over all of them
This is actually the first time I ever played this
I don't know how this will go, I think I'm doing a pretty swell job. Is this-? This is run by shit isn't it
Get some good speed
Nice
VERY
nice
10/10. Look at this. You're not gonna, you're not gonna want another game
You know what else are you gonna do with life? You're gonna want to play this game
If you haven't bought at least 20 copies yet, then what are you doing?
Okay, I'm asking
Oh God please make it
I made it everyone
I made it look at that, look how happy he is,
we beat the level. That means we beat the level okay great
We have a ton of
unlockables
We unlocked a fez everyone
incredible
now we have a hat everyone, this changes everything
*Ehee*
Oh wow that's just great. This is how you want to play the game. This is it. Look at that
You know I'm pretty much the best player in the world at this game or at least top ten
Right now, because the game isn't out yet
I mean it's out today, so it won't be lasting very long. Like I told you guys, the game is all about the community
Let's play-
someone made this one?
The game isn't even out yet, who the hell is making ding dong version 2
This looks legit
Whoa! This a user created level. I guess we'll go down
That's so cool
oh no
No! NOO
Ohmygod, no I lost my wheels, dammit. Ah okay, it's fine, we can still do this
Just time it
NOO
Yes YES
AHHGH
10/10
Ah okay, we lost the vehicle. That's fine we- never mind
stop. stop. stop.
Come on x1 million
yes,yes,YES
NO
YES
NOOOO
This is the most annoying level,
okay, okay, perfect perfect perfect perfect perfect perfect perfect
wait for the arm
Go go go go
Yes, just go- FUUUHn
I hate this game.
You know, I take it all back. This game should never have been made.
Nice and easy
We're fine, we're fine, we're finally, fine.
Now what? Now what?
YES
AGH
Okay, well here we are in the wonderful level editor. You can do all kinds of stuff
It's pretty simple to use, you just pretty much
just click, anything you think will happen will happen, control, paste, all that kind of stuff
Delete deletes. You click on it, we can change the conveyor speed
What happens if we put the five-
fifty- fifty thousand whatever
Okay well great. That's just great. Sometimes you shouldn't ask. How about we add a little
A little angle on that
Now we're gonna just
Keep making that
Steadily, just like a
Just like a nice little downhill. A nice breeze in the wind
How will that work?
Pretty flawlessly I would say
Okay, now we're gonna add some
Why don't I add some mines right?
How does this work?
That did not work at all as intended
I'm gonna call this one pewdiepie's challenge. If you guys can beat this, you're pretty good at the game
Not gonna lie you're pretty good at the game
This is practically impossible
This is the best, this is the best level. I made this level it's really good
clearly I have no skill, God dammit, I didn't know they would pop
Wow, I can't wait to see what you guys are gonna make cuz you're so much more talented than I am
*Dies*
alright so, this is a work in progress
It's probably the best map. Ever. In my opinion. It's taken me a couple years
It's sick
Ohmygod
Okay, I'm gonna be honest. I have no talent in making levels
That's why I want you guys to make some levels. I would love to play them for a video
I think it could be super fun
It's a huge part of the game the community aspect, and I can't wait to see what you guys gonna take this
this is it's probably one of the biggest projects I ever worked on myself and
honestly
It would mean the world to me if you guys decided to support this. It's only 10 bucks! cuz it's in early access we're gonna
Improve everything about it, keep making stuff
Based on you guys suggestions and what you guys enjoy and all that stuff
I would really appreciate if you check it out, link is in the description and
Hopefully we can keep making this. Thank you very much and bro fist - just kidding #squadfam